le Conseil Général de la Réunion vous
présente lien social le Conseil général
aux côtés des Réunionnais
à 20 ans on ne s'imagine pas être vieux
un jour on préfère profiter pleinement
de la vie à 40 ans on sait qu'un jour on
sera vieux et on pense même à préparer
sa retraite pour en profiter le mieux
possible
mais quand on est vieux on se fait
parfois rattraper par la réalité de la
vie et cette idée des jours paisibles à
la retraite ne profitent malheureusement
pas à tout le monde faute de moyens
financiers certaines personnes âgées ont
des retraits de six petites qu'elles
peuvent à peine assumer leurs dépenses
régulières
pourtant ces personnes ont travaillé
toute leur vie alors qui peut apporter
son soutien aux petites retraites on en
parle maintenant dans lien social
la Semaine Bleue est un événement
national destiné à valoriser nos aînés
cette semaine est pour eux un moyen de
ne pas être oublié et considéré dans la
société c'est aussi une façon de se
faire entendre sur les difficultés qu'il
rencontre
chacune de ces personnes à son histoire
madame cahier nous raconte la sienne
mais avant le ma retraite j'étais l'aide
à domicile
auxiliaire de vie des personnes âgées et
handicapées
j'ai travaillé à pied je prenais le bus
je prenais taxi je faisais à pied
pluie vent soleil
j'étais à mon travail parce que j'aimais
ça j'étais comme me dire
venez en elle ces personnes là parce
qu'il y avait ils avaient vraiment
besoin de moi à cette époque madame
Caillet se projetait dans le futur ce
voyant à la retraite avec son mari faire
des voyages et des sorties mais deux ans
avant sa retraite son employeur met la
clé sous la porte cette situation
soudaine a énormément bouleversé madame
Caillet sous le choc et à un âge un peu
avancé madame Caillet tombe gravement
malade
suite de mon travail effectuer de mon
travail de l'entreprise j'ai tombé
gravement malade j'étais opérée filation
décès après un an après
la chimio radiothérapie j'étais tombée
d'un coma pendant 3 semaines 15 jours
je suis réveillée
avec l'aide du Conseil Général m'a aidé
m'envoyer des aides à domicile l'aide à
domicile
après l'aide de mon mari de mes enfants
j'ai pu revenir
retrouver un petit peu la santé c'était
tellement dû au très très dur
j'avais au moins 60 80 kilos
je suis tombé 41 kg
j'avais une fille
qui avait qui viennent se marier à 20
ans on a mis le docteur
lâche dans mon
maladie appelle j'attendais appelle j'ai
parlé
elle est partie voir le docteur le
premier au graphique elle m'a amené
maman je suis enceinte elle avait déjà
30 ans j'étais contente pour elle c'est
ça m'a donné l'espoir de vivre voir mon
petit-fils
aujourd'hui je suis fière mon petit qui
a deux ans
pour Madame Caillet c'est un miracle de
la nature qui lui a donné la force de
vouloir vivre mais après ce combat elle
en continue un autre chaque jour après
avoir passé 30 ans à travailler elle se
retrouve avec une retraite insuffisante
une situation difficile à gérer au
quotidien le petit retraites c'est pas
suffisant de vivre nous et personne
âgées
mais à de quoi tout à payer l'eau les
sociétés
là fin d'année
les impôts qui arrivent le Conseil
général est bien conscient de certaines
difficultés de nos seniors il soutient
au mieux le troisième âge en participant
financièrement aux associations qui
s'occupent d'eux en étant en place des
dispositifs d'aide aux personnes âgées
des aides dont madame cahier profite
elle et son mari pour s'oxygéner
l'esprit et ne pas tomber dans la
solitude
mais on aime voir les gens sortir voir
les gens
changent un peu les idées reste tout
seul dans la maison c'est pas bon vous
moi j'ai dit aux personnes âgées il faut
sortir on arrive à jour domino lui et
moi quand il arrive le troisième âge moi
je la kine avec
mes copines
c'est la Réunion avance c'est qu'elle
s'appuie sur des valeurs que
nos grands moun la céder pour construire
la réunion d'aujourd'hui donc les
personnes âgées sont un trésor pour le
Réunionnais pour le Conseil général nous
apportons beaucoup d'aide de moyens pour
soutenir que ce soit les clubs ou même
les personnes qui vivent à domicile
comme nous le faisons pour des personnes
qui sont dépendantes dans les structures
ce que je souhaite c'est que nous
puissions tenir compte et c'est
l'annonce que je demanderai au
gouvernement des gens qui perçoivent des
petites retraites ceux qui vivent avec
400 euros moins de 600 euros par mois
pour que nous puissions les aider parce
que il n'y a pas de vraies dignité quand
ces personnes ont autant de mal pour
finir dans ces périodes de crise ou tout
devient plus cher pour finir les fins de
mois donc c'est la demande express que
nous ferons à Monsieur Chirec et le
Conseil Général envisagera des solutions
pour aider les petites retraites
réunionnaise
comme Madame Caillet beaucoup de
personnes âgées ont besoin d'un vrai
soutien et d'aide au quotidien
les retraites sont parfois insuffisantes
c'est une réalité que le conseil général
en tant combattre en ayant demandé à
l'État via le plan de lutte contre la
pauvreté une revalorisation des petites
retraites pour que nos grammes puissent
finir leur vie chargées d'histoire et de
valeur avec le respect des autres et la
dignité qui leur est dû
de la Réunion vous a présenté lien
social le Conseil général aux côtés des
Réunionnais